well you ready to get a gun-control
lecture next time you go to the doctor
well a recent editorial in the annals of
internal medicine urges physicians to
start publicly campaigning for gun
control well so pestering our patients
about how unsafe it is to own guns
the editorial says quote don't let your
concerns for perceived political
consequences get in the way for
advocating for the well-being of your
patients and the public dr. Christine
Lane is editor-in-chief of the annals of
internal medicine she'd caught through
that piece since she joins us tonight
doctor thanks coming on thanks for
having me Tucker so I'm I was reading
about this and you all said over the
annals that the massacre in Las Vegas
spurred you to do this and it got me
thinking would this have prevented that
do you think if you had told Steven
paddock that guns are dangerous that he
wouldn't have opened fire no and that's
not exactly what our proposal is our
proposal is to treat firearm injury like
a public health problem that it has
become and one opportunity to do that is
for in the exam room for doctors to talk
to their patients who are at risk for
injuring themselves or others with guns
about how to deal with it more safely so
but you're not an expert on guns I mean
would it make you uncomfortable if I
give you medical advice yeah that would
make me pretty uncomfortable meet you
that's why I'm gonna do it I'm not an
expert on guns but I am a medical expert
and part of what physicians do is to
assess risk and then help talk to their
patients about mitigating those risks Oh
assess risk like when you guys sent tens
of millions of doses of opioids into
Appalachia and killed over a hundred
thousand people that that kind of rest
where were you then justjust wondering I
can't help it since you've bragged about
your risk assessment abilities well risk
assessment we do assess risk and it
wasn't doctors that sent tens of million
doses of opioids
Phylicia or other places but we do
assess the risks we assess risks of high
blood pressure smoking risky sexual
behavior that puts people at risk for
infections all right when people are
elderly and it risk for Falls we asked
about area rugs in the home
we talked to patients about seatbelts
there are lots of different risks that
we assess and this proposal is that is
to remind physicians that when they have
a patient who's at risk for harming
themselves or others to ask that whether
they have guns in the home and then talk
to them about more safely storing those
guns or other interventions that can
make them and their families safer what
what would you acknowledge that there
are people who ought to have a gun in
the home like if you live alone in a
tough area where there's a lot of crime
home invasions would you ever say you
know you probably better to have some
way to defend yourself I as a physician
and I would not I don't think that that
would be in my purview to do I mean it's
certainly people's right in this country
but if that person was at risk of
harming themselves or others then I
would be counseling them that maybe it
would not be safe to have a government
but what if they were at risk of being
harmed I mean if your if the point of
this is harm reduction as you claimed it
was then I mean if someone was a
delivery man for example in a tough
neighborhood delivering the newspaper or
delivering to bodegas at three of them
absolutely what do you say it's probably
better to be armed actually Tucker there
are data out there that show that if
people have access to a gun in their
home it doesn't actually keep them safer
they're much higher risk for a completed
suicide or for a gun homicide people
that have guns in their show I just
needed to say that your assumption that
having a gun in your home keeps you
safer there really are data that refutes
that assumption yeah I don't think you
know the data really because when you
take suicide out of that it's a totally
different picture and that that's a
separate question I'd love to ask you
about whether you're against suicide and
trying to prevent suicide but let me
just ask you are you saying that there
is no circumstance where someone is
safer with a gun is that your medical
position no what I was saying is that in
a systematic review published in Annals
of internal medicine that looked at 16
studies that evaluated the risk of the
completed suicide or gun homicide by
whether or not the patient
the person had access to guns in the
home that the risk for both those things
a completed suicide and a gun homicide
was higher in in
I'm familiar with those statistics and I
and they're misleading and so I'm a
little surprised that you're setting
them because I think serious people know
that but let me just ask you this if I
said I live at the end I'm disabled and
I live at the end of a long road where
the police can't get there within ten
minutes there but home invasions I feel
I need to protect myself I feel I need a
gun would you actually say no you don't
need a gun what would be your advice I
think that's the patient's choice but if
that patient was it was depressed and at
risk for suicide or was having homicidal
ideation or had cognitive deficits
I would probably counsel them that it
was more safe for them not to have a
gunman have a gun well I think that's
fair I mean if you if you're worried the
person's gonna kill himself I think
you're absolutely right so you as an
organization have taken a strong
position against suicide it sounds like
is that right yeah no I mean not only
not opposition center for suicide I
don't think there were too many
physicians out there that advocate
suicide well I don't know like the
entire state of Oregon where it's legal
and a lot of physicians participated in
and advocated for it so yes there are a
lot of physicians in this country and in
Europe who are for suicide as you know
talking about a completely different
issue you're talking about assisted
suicide for people that have terminal
illness that are at the end of their
life that really has nothing to do with
the gun well I don't know people shoot
themselves with guns all the time when
they're in terminal pain or are facing a
terminal illness so you're just saying
suicides okay with a physician but not
alone is that your position I'm trying
to get to the nut of what you believe
I think suicide with the gun is always
pretty messy and it's not something that
physicians support and one of the things
that's lost in this guns use of the
needles and conversations what suicide
with a needle can be okay but suicide
with the gun is always wrong because
it's messy is that what you're saying no
no it's wrong because even physicians
who assisted suicide is not done with
injection drugs you're talking about
euthanasia which is not legal in this
country huh okay well you're dead at the
end no matter what so it doesn't seem
morally a different category to me but
so you disagree dr. Liang I thought we
were gonna talk about firearm injury
what we were but the majority of course
a firearm deaths are suicides as you
said and so you're trying to protect
people from that again as you said so I
was just trying to get to the nub of
what you believe because I don't think
it's enough just to come on and spew
platitudes I think it's important to
explain precisely what you believe in
what you mean and so I was trying to get
you know so if if you give me an
opportunity I will so what this what
dress I think I think I ducked or I
think I've given you I don't know six or
seven minutes and I think I think you've
had a chance to to explain it I
appreciate it thank you